you guys know I'm in this chair a lot
you guys know that I am in the podcast
iron Lords podcast and I tend to be in
these chairs a lot so your boy addict
he's been on the hunt for the best chair
and most comfortable chair you can buy
so shout out to Edwin they sent us over
this chair it is the E1 racing heavy
duty gaming chair so your boy I had to
put it through its Paces you know I've
been playing Destiny I've been playing
some Persona 5. been putting a lot of
time into this chair and today we're
going to be reviewing it let's get on
with the review so I'm sure you're
asking addict what qualifies to a chair
that I need I need a chair that I can
actually sit down and play things I need
a chair that I can do a a long Forum
podcast and not feel like my body done
got run over by a truck three or four
times I need
to hold my weight I'm a big dude if I
say so myself about 270 pounds so right
off the bat because of my weight it's
hard to find a chair that is comfortable
and can hold my weight through long
sitting such as a six hour podcast or
four or five hours of just sitting down
and playing the game for something I'm
reviewing so when Ewan reached out I was
like you know what I have a chair now
but I want to experiment I want to see
what else is out there so I had them
send it over and you know first off I
want to say the presentation for their
chairs is really good it's pretty
self-explanatory setup I'm not the
greatest person when it comes to
following directions I always mess that
stuff up what I do appreciate is they're
pretty self-explanatory to build the
chair I actually had to build pretty
fast and right onto gaming now let's
talk about when I first started this
thing all right E1 says on their website
can hold up to 550 pounds looks like
most chairs hold about 300 pounds now
like I said I'm a big dude and I'm
actually really pleasantly surprised
saying your guys like the heavyset
people I think this chair is definitely
going to hold your weight I don't think
you're gonna break through it you know
now as far as like the long-term usage
like I said I only had it for a couple
weeks but I could say even now after
putting it through its Paces I still
don't feel like it's breaking down at
all all right now that we've established
that this chair can hold my weight let's
talk about the comfort of the chair when
I sat down the first thing I realized is
that the seat itself can hold my whole
self it I don't feel like I'm cramped in
the chair I feel like there's plenty of
room to go left and right I remember I I
had a chair a long time ago that like
kind of wrapped around me a little bit
in the back of the chair not not so much
this one I felt like this was a good fit
and like I said built for big people
good kudos to them now one thing I will
say is like the actual armrest was a
little uncomfortable but you can easily
buy stuff on Amazon and I'm kind of
making a little bit more comfortable
when you put your hands on and I'm not
going to sit there and say it was like
the worst experience in the world what I
would say as far as like the cushion
that you actually sit on clearly is way
more comfortable than where you put your
elbows and I think that obviously when
it comes to something like that that's
least important when it comes to you
know the back support you have or just
putting your elbows down in general but
I did want you guys to know that you
know that is the only thing in in form
of comfort that I could tell you was a
little bit lacking now obviously the
armrests they go up and down clearly
most gaming chairs do that recently here
you know you can recline it I do like
the recline feature of this it actually
feels like the back end of the actual
chair is it gonna break when I lean back
in it and I really enjoy that because
sometimes like my back gets like this
cringing it helps when I actually
recline the back and it helps a lot with
that now let's talk about the Aesthetics
of the E1 gaming chair I think it looks
slick you know it's definitely the
standard black gaming chair that you see
everywhere I think they've kind of went
away from you know a whole lot of color
now obviously they sell different
variety of colors on their website I
just like the black versions because I
feel like they look better with my
actual rig with my setup I think it just
looks aesthetically a lot better so in
conclusion
the E1 racing heavy duty gaming chair
was a solid experience for me and I know
a lot of content creators podcasters
streamers you guys are following this
channel you love the podcast and you see
how long I'm in podcast you see how long
I sit down comfort of of a chair is
important and I definitely think this is
a solid experience you know if you are
interested in this chair this E1 heavy
gaming Duty chair in the description
there's going to be a a link use the
code iron
and uh get 20 off your chair and I hope
you guys enjoyed this chair as much as I
have enjoyed this chair and I can't wait
to use it for these long gaming sessions
of Starfield I'm about to do with it
this is gaming addict Lord addict thank
you for watching peace